there's currently no confirmation of a
sequel to Five Nights at Freddy's going
into development but the chances of it
happening are very high the film already
made its money back before it even hit
theaters thanks to the sale of streaming
and Theatrical distribution rights so
what could happen in a potential sequel
the ending of the film doesn't give many
hints nor does the mid credit scene
since it's basically just a fun scare
gag with the balloon boy statue we can
guess though that the movies will
probably continue the story of the games
remixing some of the events and
introductions it's worth noting that the
film doesn't follow the game's beat beat
and introduces things that don't appear
until later games for instance
springtrap who is represented by aton's
costume Choice doesn't appear until the
third game this means that other unseen
characters and locations can appear at
any point the sequel could also weave
together plot points from the other
games to create a narrative cocktail of
the franchise's best parts so while a
Five Nights at Freddy sequel is almost
certainly on the horizon it won't
exactly be predictable for fans of the
games